[Music]
[Music]
the freedom of speech is a freedom and
it like all freedoms it comes with
responsibilities the fact that you're
free to say certain things say about the
Prophet Muhammad or whatever it might be
doesn't mean that you should necessarily
say them I think that people should be
free to say the things that Charlie
Hebdo said but I think Charlie Hebdo
shouldn't have said them because I think
it was just there was no point in doing
so and it it achieved absolutely nothing
of any use but but they're two different
things one is them believing that people
should be free to say things the other
once you are free knowing how to use
that freedom and that they're distinct
but what does happen a lot is that
people will use claims of being offended
or insulted as reasons for shutting down
freedom of speech and that's completely
illegitimate freedom of speech is is
limited only in my view by the the
jurisprudence around the First Amendment
of the US Constitution and therefore the
obvious cliche about not being able to
shout fire in a crowded theater about
about not be able to incite violence
these are the limits on freedom of
speech which a free society can accept
and tolerate but beyond that people
should be free to say what they like and
after that it's governed by morality
well our biggest challenge as a society
is that millions of people have been
taught what to think and hardly anybody
has been taught how to think and so far
too many things are taken on trust and
people get away with far too much
foreign and domestic policy and
generally in public discourse you can
say fantastically stupid things and get
away with it no it's not done our
political correctness is a two-edged
thing the political crevices is popular
and successful because a lot of it's
something about being
being kind to people and having good
manners and no one's against that and
also it's a very complicated field in
which the whole argument about about
diversity and equality gets quite
difficult if you go into it so know what
I fundamentally blame it on is the
destruction of state education system in
the 1960s you could used to be able to
tell before the House of Lords was was
flooded with cronies if you went to the
houses apartment and attended a debate
in the House of Commons where most of
the people were educated since the 1960s
and then went along the corridor to the
House of Lords where most of the people
being educated before the nineteen
sixties you could see the difference
instantly and the way they form their
sentences and the levels of knowledge
they displayed and it was a very good
contrast that's gone now but it actually
does Illustrated there was a revolution
in education at that time and those who
lived before it are totally distinct
from those who came after it and it
wasn't just that the grammar schools
were destroyed the grammar schools kept
all the other schools including the
private schools honest and once they
were gone the standards of everybody
slipped no I don't i long ago gave up
putting forward solutions to everything
I thought well I've written all these
books saying this is what has gone wrong
and by implication what you could do to
put it right and no one paid any
attention at all so I've now reached a
conclusion that we're all going to sing
giggling into the sea at some point in
the very near future and there's nothing
whatever you can do about it except if
you if you're really worried leave
before it's too late
I'm too old for me I just I was only
making myself unhappy trying to do
something about it
and as soon as I stopped trying to do
anything about it it was a great weight
off my shoulders it's not my
responsibility anymore
we're going to discuss the central
question is offense an inevitable part
of free society or should we stamp it
out Joanna so I think the right to be
offensive is absolutely vital in a
society that purports to uphold a belief
in free speech for one thing we don't
need the right to free speech for what's
inoffensive we can be as bland and as
boring as we like and nobody is ever
going to challenge us we only need the
right to be the right to free speech and
it becomes meaningful and important when
we're going to say things that might
upset other people my second argument is
that free speech and most importantly
the right to be offensive is necessary
for society to advance if you think
about all the major leaps forward we've
made as a society whether we're talking
about abolishing slavery universal
suffrage gay marriage anything you can
think of evolution all of these ideas
have grossly offended some sections of
society and if we didn't have the right
to offend we wouldn't have been able to
argue for those our cause as which I
think we would all agree now are hugely
progressive and really important we need
to be able to offend to make the case
for those things
the final point I'd make and this is
where I am so sorry asthma but I just
don't know why you would be here today
if you think words can't change its
cause debates oh yes yes exactly debates
so important to try and change people's
minds to change people's views ideally
because words are important what's a
very important time indeed because
however much we might wish it were
otherwise we can't just magic bad ideas
away and there are an awful lot of bad
ideas out there in the world and we need
to beg we need the right to be offensive
we need free speech to be able to
challenge those bad ideas well I want to
go back to what Joanna said I think that
shows really quite worrying inability to
because
it's really important well I'm sure yes
but just somebody calls me a [ __ ] it
isn't it makes no difference if somebody
else defends me because the wound that
sense of feeling utterly alone and
diminished it remains with you for a
long time this is what people don't
understand I wanted to reply to that in
particular but you're asking me a
specific question I think ideas even
ideas even ideas we think we're very
free minded and open about our
controlled and David's given a very good
example the BBC could not have a program
on Holocaust denial but the beat but we
have prevent we have a whole government
policy right which is saying you cannot
have ideas of Islamic extremism brought
to university to be discussed this is
part of the regulation I'm a professor
at Middlesex we are told to look out for
such debates I don't agree with that but
I can see why they're doing it but can't
description I just pick up two points
with you ever make one is you said
Joanna I'm sure didn't mean to but
offended you or didn't understand the
nature of the offense you feel when
you're lucky I think all right what does
that mean because you are hurt by that
you would stop people saying it yes I
don't want people to say [ __ ] how many
people here need feel the need to say
[ __ ] please put your hand up you would
one out of how many yeah no I don't want
to be called packing I don't want words
lead to places Rhonda Bosnia how many
more examples do you need
[Music]
well I think to lead on from what you're
saying you know we live in the shadow of
the war on terror you know it's gone on
longer than World War one and World War
two put together and part of what we
have witnessed from the kind of backlash
in some way the blowback from the war on
terror has been for select citizens a
death of habeas corpus so what I mean by
that is that you have a situation where
people within this country can be
detained without ever percy being able
to have access to the evidence against
them or being judged by a jury of their
peers we live in a time when a child
from a Muslim family shall we say or a
family that our racialized as Muslims
can be sitting in class learning about
the Magna Carta and all of the rights
that that affords them simultaneously
they could have a family member in
prison and again like I said without
ever seeing the evidence held against
them without ever being judged by a jury
of their peers and possibly being
extradited to the United States that
child themselves could also Samia Slee
be reported to prevent for wearing a
badge which says free Palestine that's
the context within which we live and
myself is in Iraqi who was here
throughout the 2003 war my feeling of
what can and can't be said what can and
can't be questioned what violence is
sacred and what violence is benign has
been something that I have actually felt
constraints from so if I decide to
visible eyes in my music the violence of
an arms company like BAE Systems there
are repercussions in my private life and
what I mean by that is detained in
airport what I mean by that is you know
in some cases the BBC not wanting to
play certain songs or have me on at
certain times say for instance I was due
to be on Tim Westwood show on September
the 11th
and 11 and I was rung up at the last
minute and said we don't want you on
there and the reason they didn't want me
on there is because it was September the
8th and this is and this is something
that is when you are able to invisible
eyes the contours and mechanisms of
power what then happens to those who see
it and who want to speak about it and so
in kind of answering to your point there
is art that is being created during
these times have actually immense horror
of actually immense horror and there are
people that see that horror there are
people that try and speak about it try
and deal with it try and find a way to
heal through art during these times but
I think those people really are on the
front line of those that are being
silenced I feel like you're saying that
art might come from an experience of
discontent or deprivation but it's also
an eloquent response to it but also you
might suffer the repercussions of it but
also also the examples we have of people
that have done that is actually a
testament to the human spirit that has
existed you know for instance there's an
amazing book by Peter Viktor Tsoi
Frankel who survived the Holocaust and
what he said to himself is that I
constantly would picture myself
surviving this terrible this terrible
situation and lecturing about it
afterwards and he drew strength from the
saying that a person who has a Y can
bear anyhow and the point is that I
think that our strengthens and
consolidates the spirit in that way
[Music]
in our democracy in the real world and
have rules freedom of speech doesn't
mean absolute freedom to say anything
you want at any point in time everywhere
it comes with a responsibility it goes
the freedom of one goes to where it
infringes on the freedom of another you
know the freedom from being demonized
the freedom from being abused and that's
why freedom of speech works in the real
world democracy because we have those
protections built in and solid
protection we have decided because we
have voted politicians in place through
generations that build up the democracy
we live in today and it's just those
same rules we shall make to apply on the
Internet
because what you're saying ends up in
what we're seeing now which is anarchy
and anarchy is not freedom for everybody
anarchy is always rule of the bully and
the bully is the mock culture that we
see and if you have as I have an
announcement on been subject to online
bullying hacking undermining identity
theft you have no doubt that you rather
have a garment regulate than the mobs
and to come back this - we need the
oversight of all those to be here well
yes unless we have a very strong
internal human compass if we really can
distinguish right and wrong ourselves we
don't need others to keep an eye on but
most of us who have lived more or less
mono culturally and without I mean even
within a country but in a certain
village type of community where there
are rights and wrongs we don't even know
we don't have a personal compass that if
we are on our own and total different
culture we wouldn't even need know what
is right or wrong but if we have been
challenged then we develop that human
compass you know if you're put in
another culture you actually may be
killing is allowed but you say no I
don't like to kill that's sure that you
have your own personal human compass
regardless of your surroundings if we
have that there would not be a problem
with the Internet the problem is that we
don't have
around the world cultures where we
developed out and I also don't think is
realistic to have this willing a
reasonable timeframe therefore we do
need oversight for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you